a man is humiliated in the street by a
police officer
this shepherd is being reprimanded and
pushed apparently because his sheep got
too close to the local government
headquarters
[Music]
the video has led to protests that also
include the state of the economy
joblessness and police violence they
came a decade after a street vendor set
himself on fire in protest over the same
issues
an event that became a catalyst for the
2011 revolution in tunisia and the arab
spring
earlier in the day prime minister hisham
mishishi had reshuffled the cabinet
adding 12 new ministers to carry out
reforms including new ministers of
health
interior justice and energy
the aim of this reshuffle is to achieve
greater efficiency in the work of the
government's policy and plans
many view the timing as important
thursday was the anniversary of the
downfall of president xena abedin
benally who was forced out in a popular
revolution that swept the region
but with demonstrations banned because
of the coronavirus there were no
commemorations on the streets
but in at least six cities protesters
defied those orders
in confrontations with police officers
protesters across the country
once again being heard in the capitol
andrew chappelle al jazeera